[Music]
to get started with pub/sub first make
sure the pub/sub api is enabled for your
project then go to the pub sub page in
the Google cloud platform console click
create a topic enter a unique name for
your topic for example my topic that's
it you've just created a cloud pub/sub
topic to add a subscription to the topic
you've just created use the display menu
for the topic you've just created and
click new subscription type a name for
the subscription my sub this is case
sensitive so do make sure you capitalize
the M and the S leave the delivery type
is pull and click create to publish a
message to the topic in the overflow
menu for the topic you've just created
click publish message enter hello world
in the message field click publish to
receive the message you just published
your subscription needs to perform a
pull operation one way to do this is
through the g-cloud command line tool
you can use the Google Cloud SDK locally
but here we'll use the in console of
cloud shell to run the following g-cloud
command from the guide the message you
sent appears in the data field of the
command output congratulations
you've just created a cloud pub/sub
topic subscription and pull request to
that subscription
[Music]